there was no warning for this ban on
women attending University was there so
how surprising was this step by the
Taliban
well actually you cannot imagine how it
feels um unless you have been a girl who
grew up in Afghanistan
I was devastated by the announcement not
because it was unexpected of Taliban
but because I cannot picture how the
next policy how the next restriction
would look like for a woman in
Afghanistan says the daily bone stepped
into power in Afghanistan the only thing
they have been focusing on was how to
further sub question how to further
restriction on women and as you see the
countries on the verge of starvation we
lose children every day tomorrow
nutrition and
the population is in need of in
disparate need of Public Services that
authorities should provide
while Taliban the only ideology they
have today and the only thing they
they're focusing on is how to spread
their misogynistic ideology by just
restricting women from their very basic
rights and you cannot imagine
how dark the situation is the starvation
the depression the Suffocation it's it's
reaching to a Breaking Point especially
for women and
apologies I didn't mean to interrupt
interrupt you I was only going to
mention the fact that there were
restrictions already on women in
universities weren't they they were only
allowed to study certain subjects they
had different entrances they were only
allowed to be taught by women or some
older men for example have you been able
to speak to anybody there and get some
reaction to those who found that they
have their University careers ended
well I've been in contact with most
University students Family University
students in Afghanistan because
um I've tried to mobilize forces both in
Afghanistan and outside in order to
preserve the spaces that we have already
got in Afghanistan but included
University level education for women
and the day when I was interviewing some
of the students with this initiative
which I cannot mention for Safety and
Security reasons
um we have heard about the announcement
and a lot of students
who were on the verge of graduation a
lot of students who were just hoping
just just just
um keeping up with the little space they
have got they they were completely
devastated
um I heard from my classmates
um because I couldn't finish my studies
and I lived Afghanistan some of my
classmates who were back in Afghanistan
they were telling me that when
universities opened they were going back
to their classes but it looked like a
funeral everybody was wearing black and
it seemed like even the trees and the
ground they were decaying
and and the whole situation was was
quite suffocating slowly shrinking for
women but they were they were keeping up
with it they they still they were still
going with with all their heart and all
their passion because they knew what the
alternative would look like
but the announcement it came at a time
when girls have been already back from
attending high school for over a year
now
and the fact that we still see the world
it is standing by and just watching
um and waiting for the taliban's
behavior to change with sanctions that
starving Japanese civilians it is it is
absurd it is
and it is not something that could ever
change the situation of women in
Afghanistan well yes what would you like
to see happened clearly this step has
been condemned by the UN it's been
condemned by countries around the world
but what would you like the
International Community to do now
the fact that I want
it's a necessity like breathing oxygen
and education crisis is emergency and if
International Community do not join
forces right now with big powerful
institutions if they do not take a
stance right now we might lose the only
educated generation that we have got in
the country that is the only hope for
Afghanistan because I think you cannot
be neutral in this situation education
is political woman is political in
Afghanistan and if the U.N and big
institutions if they do not take a
stands and if they in the in the sake of
political correctness or neutrality if
they remain silent and just rely on
empty works and condemnations then they
are equally responsible for the state of
women in Afghanistan like Taliban
okay well Aisha Quran thanks very much
indeed to for giving us your time and
your reaction to that ban of women in
Afghanistan from University we
appreciate your time thank you